I had originally planned to begin this
week with a topic that had to be pushed
off after the trans terrorist shooting
at the Christian School here in
Nashville but now in light of the events
of this week it takes on I think an even
more uh even more urgency so on Monday
morning the Wall Street Journal
published poll results which uh throw
into Stark relief a certain cultural
reality that has been clear to some of
us for a long time but not nearly clear
enough to most of us the publication
reports quote patriotism religious Faith
having children and other priorities
that helped Define the national
character for Generations are receding
in importance to Americans a new Wall
Street Journal norc poll finds the
survey conducted with norc at the
University of Chicago a nonpartisan
research organization also finds the
country sharply divided by political
party over social trends such as the
push for racial diversity in businesses
and the use of gender-neutral pronouns
some 38 of respondents said patriotism
was very important to them and 39 said
religion was very important that was
down sharply from from when the journal
asked the question of the first time in
1998 when 70 percent deemed part uh
patriotism to be very important and 62
percent said so of religion the sheriff
Americans who say that having children
involvement in their community and hard
work are very important has also Fallen
tolerance for others deemed very
important by 80 of Americans as recently
as four years ago has fallen to 58 since
then the only priority the journal
tested that has grown in importance in
the past quarter century is money which
was cited as very important by 43
percent in the new survey which was up
from 31 in 1998.
now by the way the fact that people
value money is of course not in itself a
bad thing I mean I value money I value
money a lot because it's how I provide
for my family so it is very important
but the problem is that while people
value money more than they did in the
past they don't value hard work nearly
as much and they don't value having
children so this tells us that many
Americans want money for their own sake
to buy things for themselves but they
don't want to work for it
so it's like the worst of all worlds
great you know it's it's one thing to be
hard-working and greedy it's not good to
be greedy but if you're hard-working and
greedy you can even achieve great things
motivated that way
um but to be but to be greedy and lazy
at the same time is the again the worst
of all worlds
as expected um the Gap in values can be
seen not just across decades but also by
comparing Generations The Wall Street
Journal again reports quote aside from
money all age groups including seniors
attached far less importance to these
priorities and values than when
pollsters asked about them in 1998 and
in 2019 but younger Americans in
particular place a low importance on
these values many of which were Central
to the lives of their parents some 23 of
adults under age 30 said in the new
survey that patriotism was very
important to them personally compared
with 59 percent of seniors ages 65 or
older
some 31 percent of younger respondents
said that religion was very important to
them compared with 55 percent among
seniors only 23 of adults under age 30
said that having children was very
important
um and there's a lot more to the results
but those I think are the highlights or
low lights depending on how you look at
it now I normally don't lend a lot of
credibility or weight to polls and
surveys but these results simply
quantify help us to visualize something
that was already well apparent to
anybody who was remotely paying
attention
we are
um a culture that has increasingly
abandoned all of the values and
priorities and principles that defined
not only past generations of Americans
but all generations of all people who
have ever lived anywhere on the planet
these are for the most part Universal or
what used to be Universal human values
that are now fading away dying out in
this country
and and here's what we need to
understand about all this
first and foremost this this is the
agenda okay these results have been
engineered it's not the product of
happenstance or uh you know the
inevitable conclusion of the passage of
time as Camilla Harris would say
human civilization existed for thousands
of years and for thousands of years all
cultures everywhere though separated by
time and location
still all valued family
procreation religion patriotism hard
work achievement
these values manifested themselves in
different ways obviously took on
different forms but nearly everyone
would have agreed on the most basic
fundamentals here
you could have
uh you know pick almost any time in the
past in the year 1803 or or 1555 or you
know 300 BC you could have pulled anyone
anywhere even people removed from each
other by oceans or generations and they
would have said yes of course I value
family yes of course I want to have
children and continue my bloodline and
you know pass down wealth and prosperity
to my progeny yes of course I love my
country my community My Tribe yes of
course I worship my God or my gods yes
of course I believe that I should work
and you know do some kind of work and
provide for myself and my family
these are the answers you would have
heard anywhere
it is only now here in this culture at
this time that people will tell you they
fundamentally don't care about any of
that
the last agenda has been precisely this
to eat away at these core essential
human values to destroy the very things
that have have defined individuals and
Nations for millennia
the these are the things that that make
a person a person and a People a people
and this is also what the culture war is
all about
okay it's about on our side defending
these basic values when we call
ourselves conservatives this is
what we're trying to conserve so when
you hear someone scoff at the culture
War
this is what they're scoffing
they're scoffing at the notion that we
should even bother defending the core
human values that bind a civilization
together and ensure its continued
flourishing
when someone dismisses the culture war
and says it's uh you know it's silly
it's unimportant
tired of all these culture War issues
well they are dismissing as unimportant
and as silly the priorities and beliefs
that are rooted deepest in the human
soul
who cares about it what priorities and
beliefs were the deepest human soul what
does that matter
and what happens when those roots are
torn out
is a a new tree planted in its place no
there's nothing else to plant
so all that's left is a whole
and that's all they intend to leave
this is the way it always works
they tear out the thing and they tear it
out by the roots and they PLA and they
put nothing you just have a hole there
in the ground
they want to take away everything
everything you love and value and
replace it with emptiness
that's why the decline in these values
has not been answered with an increase
in new values now sure people might say
they value diversity and inclusion and
Equity or whatever but first of all it
doesn't take much to see that
They Don't Really value any of of that
but second those aren't real values
anyway those are slogans those are
things that you you people put on
posters uh those are those are those are
values for HR seminars okay that's what
those values are they are not values for
Nations
they aren't values for Civilizations for
human beings
in the past people who valued family and
children and God religion Faith country
hard work sacrifice they were driven by
those values to achieve extraordinary
things
okay to achieve like everything that we
benefit
from today
all the things that we have and the
luxuries we take for granted and the
rights we take for granted all of that
was given to us by people who value all
of the things that we are now discarding
these are the people who discovered new
lands and who built Nations out of
wilderness and invented things and built
things I made made beautiful art and and
sailed across seas and figured out how
to fly and how to go into space
it requires skill and intelligence to do
those things both of which are also in
short supply these days but but but you
also won't even attempt to do them
unless you value something Beyond
yourself
a man must know how to do something
great
but he must first be motivated to even
bother trying
we used to produce people like that
the people who built the civilization
that we're now destroying
because we instilled in them from birth
the values that would drive and sustain
them in their pursuit of something great
so what I'm saying is that
when we talk about valuing family
and procreation children God Work
country Faith sacrifice
these are not just the best values for
forming and maintaining a civilization
they are the only ones
that's it
they're the only game in town there are
no alternatives
if you do not value those things
then you are left with nothing you are
left as a person who values nothing
and you are left with a culture that
values nothing
you either value those or you value
nothing there are no other options
now there were some there are some who
would say well if you don't value those
things you know instead you value
yourself it's it's like a selfish thing
but even that's not exactly true because
if you value yourself the way you ought
to Value yourself
you would care about family country
children Etc
you know if you value yourself you're
not gonna you're not gonna embrace your
own Extinction the extinction of your
bloodline
and say I don't I don't need to have
children I don't need I don't need any
purpose in life I don't need to you know
I'll die alone and be forgotten and I'm
okay with that
if you value yourself you wouldn't be
you wouldn't be okay with that
so no instead our culture um cultivates
a population
which values
you know with with people and
individuals who value not even really
themselves per se but more specifically
their own comfort and the satisfaction
of their own immediate desires Above All
Else
and dostoevsky's words they they value
the multiplication and Rapid
satisfaction of Desire
that's what the whole culture is about
now that's it
okay you ask someone to ask somebody the
meaning of life
and if they're even articulate enough to
explain it that's what that's what it is
to them
the rapid satisfaction and
multiplication of Desire this is what we
have replaced the old values with
a man isn't driven to love his country
and his God to work hard for his family
and for his children rather he's called
by the culture to focus on to Champion
to celebrate and to satisfy his desires
the more desires the better the more
depraved and degenerate the better
these are the new values of the new man
and it's what we're fighting against
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
move over to members block become a
member today by using Code wall should
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
hopes you over the members block if not
we'll talk to you tomorrow got
[Music]
[Applause]